Tom Brady seeking out lamar jackson
after the game to tell him that he had a
great game on sunday night oh and he did
and it's one of those games Peter Sims
and I talked about this yesterday when
you look at Lamar Jackson's stats they
don't scream out great game 163 passing
yards 61 rushing yards okay
fine but when you consider the plays he
made when he made them in the impact
that he had on the Patriots defense and
the ability to win the game about 17
points it was a huge game for Lamar
Jackson it was an MVP type of a game for
the second-year quarterback you know
we've fallen in love so much with stats
Mike and in saying what somebody's
rating was and look Russell Wilson's
numbers were absurd 378 5 touchdowns no
picks and and I think he's the front
front runner right now for the MVP but
Lamar Jackson is close and he did play
an mvp-type game and and and Mike
afterwards I found him talk to him a
little bit at his locker away from the
scrum Mike silver and Jared Bell and I
got him alone for a little while and the
one thing that really impressed me about
Lamar Jackson is he plays so well it you
know at these very very big moments but
I'm gonna read you the quote that really
impressed me the most about Lamar
Jackson I don't really care about the
person I'm playing against I don't care
if it's a primetime game or we're
playing it 1 o'clock
I'm just trying to win at the end of the
day and you say ok spout the cliches all
that but the guys in that locker room
say that is the essence of Lamar Jackson
you got a game you got a game in the
Bill Parcells used to say I want guys
who want to play Sunday if the stadium's
closed and the games in the Paramus Park
Paramus mall parking lot and that's what
Lamar Jackson is he's a ballplayer and
and I just walked in through that locker
room there's none of this there's none
of this divided team there is this team
that feels like Lamar Jackson this 22
year
kid is our leader and we love them and
let me take that and apply a twist to it
because there's another team that wears
purple who has a quarterback who has
hyper aware of the circumstances
surrounding any given game and if it's a
big game all of a sudden the passes
start sailing four feet over the heads
of the open receivers if it's not a big
game that passes right between the
numbers and that's Kirk Cousins Lamar
Jackson for the same reason that he
embraces and would love to play a game
in the parking lot at the mall he also
is unaffected he's unflustered by a big
game that's the kind of game on a Sunday
night against the Patriots that would
freak you out any other quarterback
especially at Kirk Cousins didn't affect
Lamar Jackson at all and I think that's
a big part of his greatness no question
at all Mike he he was you know we gave
him a couple of chances to say oh my god
Tom Brady you just you just beat the
great Brady and he was having none of it
he said hey look that's the goat that's
the greatest but I don't really care i I
can't care and and I think the one thing
that I was thinking about this walking
out of the stadium that night that that
what an incredible day this must have
been for him but also Mike how about the
son of Massachusetts
Eric decosta grew up a few miles from
from from Foxborough grew up loving the
Patriots all of his friends and
everybody back home still loved the
Patriots and he has helped build a team
now that might be every bit the equal of
the Patriots and beat them Sunday night
but if you're in that position you're in
the Lamar Jackson position you can't sit
back and say hey man I choreographed a
team that beat the great Belichick or
man I beat Brady tonight that's it you
just can't think that way you got to
think I'm their peer I'm on their level
now let's go out and compete and I think
that's precisely what Lamar Jackson's
attitude is and you mentioned Acosta
he's the guy that worked the draft board
to get Lamar Jackson and as I recall
what I had heard back at the time
Jackson
drafted Steve bisciotti the owner of the
team and they say all the owners aren't
involved in the Drake yes yeah yeah when
it comes to quarterbacks the owners
always got an opinion the question is do
you pay attention to it or do you not
but shotty one of jacks in the middle of
the round and bisciotti was persuaded to
be patient that they could play this out
and they traded down and then they
traded up and they swooped in and they
get Lamar Jackson at number 32 and they
were ecstatic and you know I remember at
the time people were just like hey uh
Baker Mayfield and Sam darn old and Josh
Allen Josh Rosen Yan Lamar Jackson like
nobody really knew what to make a Lamar
Jackson and nobody thought Peter that he
would play at the NFL level the way he
played at the college level because it
was Louisville and they're playing a
bunch of overmatched defense isn't sure
he can run around those guys he's not
gonna run around and through and throw
the ball like he did when he's facing
NFL caliber defenses well just like
deshaun Watson stepped up to the next
level and became better relatively
speaking it looks like Lamar Jackson's
in the process of doing the same damn
thing Mike I think going back to the
draft the Baltimore Ravens were ready
for a clear challenge to Joe Flacco at
quarterback they kind of moved on
mentally a little bit from Joe and I
think that Lamar Jackson became that guy
in that draft who they wanted at the
right value in that draft to try to
basically say Joe Flacco now you've got
a challenger and if you're not clearly
better we're gonna go with the kid which
is exactly what they did two other quick
points I think that the Cincinnati
Bengals picking in the 20s I kept saying
that year take Lamar Jack's and take
Lamar Jackson
they took Billy Price the center guard
from Ohio State who has been it can't
even win a starting job cleanly and the
second thing I'll tell you Mike being in
that Stadium on Sunday night the Ravens
had gotten kind of stale two and three
and four years ago and they really got
got beat up by their fans for some of
their players kneeling remember that
game in London against Jacksonville
where a lot of their players
Nield in support of colin kaepernick
their fans were furious at that and I
just think it led to a little bit of a
disconnect between the Ravens and their
fans and the Ravens as I say got stale
that was a different crowd on Sunday
night Mike there were a lot of
african-americans in and around the
stadium there was one guy right in front
of the press box the press box in
Baltimore is low and one guy wore a huge
and profane Lamar Jackson sweatshirt he
stood in front of the press box held up
the sweater you know went like this with
him so we could read his sweatshirt and
I kind of nodded and I said I get it I
get it you love Lamar that crowd loves
Lamar Jackson and I think it was
desperately needed on and off the field
for the Ravens I'm trying to I'm trying
to envision what the profane swear I
assumed that there was a middle name
that was given to Lamar Jackson that's
gay with a seven letter with a seven
letter middle name Mike you're
absolutely right
Lamar Francis Jackson ladies and
gentlemen that he said actually what it
was he said after the draft when he went
number 32 overall they're gonna get a
Super Bowl out of me and he's had that
confidence all along and and off they go
even when they had joy and I remember
how awkward it was for Joe Flacco he
knew what was coming and and he came in
now Lamar Jackson MVP candidate taking
the league by storm and knocking off the
Patriots Peter Mike there's one other
point I want to make on this sometimes I
bet initially Lamar Jackson felt like oh
my god thirty first pick all these
quarterbacks getting picked ahead of me
I mean Josh Rosen 22 picks ahead of me
and I don't get this sense that Lamar
Jackson felt oh my god this is awful I
always got the sense man I'm lucky I
went to a good team and every time you
know he's like and I'm not comparing him
to Dan Marino other than in position of
the draft dan Marino got to be drafted
by a good team because people had
questions about him coming out of pit
and and and I look at this is almost the
same thing for Lamar Jackson it's a
blessing that he went 32nd in my opinion
because you're going to a team that has
a lot of pieces already in place and
that it's proven over and over again
that through analytics and through the
ability like compensatory picks they
know how to run a modern NFL franchise I
doubt he knew any of this on the day of
the draft but he sure does know it now
you know just a few weeks ago it could
be argued that the Ravens weren't as
good as four and two would have
indicated they had a closed home win
against the bengals a closed home win
against the cardinals they lost at home
to the Browns then here we go at Seattle
they win by 14 they take down the
Patriots by 17 and they're right up
there at the upper echelon of the NFL
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports